griffin jacks has been riding the rookie
roller coaster up and down and it's
really what you try and avoid but it's
one of the hardest things to do and he's
going to go out there and try and get
back to where he was in the middle part
of
those 10 starts
really location is going to be important
for him obviously working ahead is
important for every pitcher but
fastball command yes but that secondary
stuff the slider has to be able to get
it down where he wants it to and
generate some swings and misses with
that pitch as well in his last start
against kansas city six innings four
earned runs first pitch lifted high
fairly deep left center field
gliding after it buxton one pitch one
out
and buxton can draw to his left this
time
three pitches two flyouts two away
drilled to right
kepler
and play the carom and ramirez digging
for two and
the throw right there on three hops
kepler had a hard time digging it out of
his glove but his throw was eventually
right on the money a single for ramirez
thrown out at second cleveland will take
a look at it but the inning has ended
cal making
his fourth start
against minnesota this year his records
five and three overall 304 era he's been
on a nice roll for the tribe
he got the barrel out that time but
bradley zimmer with a terrific play on
the warning track for route number one
buxton pulls that to third and ramirez
will throw him out he delivers
and it's swung on in a weak ground ball
into the shift and shallow right the
second baseman chang has it throws them
out andres jimenez will lead things off
for cleveland in the third inning
that's towards the seam
backhanded by polanco and a nice pick at
first by miguel ceneaux
backhanding it we've seen him make that
throw and that's one that second baseman
have to make these days and it helps
when the second baseman used to be a
shortstop yeah you know shortstop you
make a lot more throws on the run like
this you don't have time to set your
feet and i think you know for everyone
to say why doesn't he just stop well on
the grass it's not quite as easy and all
of a sudden you lose your footing and
you throw the ball away there you get it
out of your hand you trust that guy at
first base and does a nice job he misses
low you miss high he can't help you no
no mercado
and the 2-2 in down goes mercado on a
breaking ball strikes out swinging
second punch out for jacks that's a good
slider there that's the one you can
bottle that that spiked slider that he
throws where he kind of digs that
fingernail into the seam miles straw
acquired from houston
high fly center field and buxton two is
right byron's got it and that's a one
two three
third advances to third but now there's
two down now bobby bradley will step in
and see if he can't put the indians in
front
yes bobby bradley lines one up the alley
and left center field that'll get down
buxton cuts it off the indians are on
the board bradley digging for two and
he's in there safely with a two out rbi
double and it's one to nothing cleveland
is bobby bradley has his tenth double in
his 34th run batted in on the year yeah
but that's a perfect swing to stay on
the baseball takes what's given and
that's a nice double and he hustles his
way into second base so
big two out hit for bradley to get the
indians on the board and he's done that
and he seems to do that a little bit
more when you get runners in scoring
positions here's mercato
struck out first time up indians with a
one-run lead here in the fifth looking
for more
mercado with a drive to deep left field
that's gonna get out of here and it's a
three-run homer for the indians as they
explode here in the fifth and make it a
four to nothing lead home run number
five for oscar mercado
well you could tell they were getting uh
they're getting to him because they
started hitting the ball hard he makes a
bad pitch and they finally jump on one
and hit it out there's a hanging slider
there's the home run they've been
looking for he's given up now
19 homers and in eight consecutive games
this one's not coming back and mercado
knew he had it as soon as he hit it now
jose ramirez will step in
he's driven to left late start for cave
but he recovers and makes the catch just
shy of the warning track tagging and
scoring from third is straw
and it's a sac fly for jose ramirez the
indians now lead it five nothing one
ball one strike
that's the center
straw
dives and makes a nice catch in center
field mile straw with a good jump
and a great angle and a jump at the end
with a catch
jake caves going
and that bad luck wouldn't have any luck
at all first at bat he hit a ball 95
miles an hour right in the shortstop
stop here he said all right i'll try to
handle a little bit see if i can get the
bloop in
straw playing a little bit shallow gets
a good jump on this ball you see the
focus and down and hangs on nice play
right there left on left here's bradley
zimmer oh for three
and mile straw is going to hit second
and go for third buckston's throw is not
in time and now trying to get the second
and the throw goes away
zimmer forced a bad throw
scoring his straw bradley gets to third
base and it's six to nothing cleveland
yeah it'll be another error by minnesota
one out and jose ramirez is at the plate
oh he smacked it right back up the
middle got by polanco his third hit of
the night his second run batted in it's
now seven to nothing cleveland ramirez
now at second on the wild pitch seven
nothing tribe and a full count on reyes
base hit into right center ramirez will
score to make it eight nothing indians
fran mill reyes with his second hit and
his 76th rbi well the indians have
completely blown this thing wide open by
a score of eight to nothing here in the
seventh inning with a runner on giovanni
moran out of the game and now we'll see
andrew albers one out one on three in
eight nothing cleveland here in the
seventh
oh did he get it yes did he get it
good bye
bobby bradley sends one to the upper
tank and right center field
and the indians have exploded for a five
run seventh inning and their lead is now
10
to nothing well here is ceno he has the
only twins head
drilled to left
and that's a three-run home run sono has
both hits against quantrill 10-3 we got
bases loaded nobody out and a chance for
a huge inning again
there's your pull
and there's your double play
jimenez will score
grandma reyes the indians clean up
hitter will lead off to ninth 11-3
paul is cleveland
deep and up into the second level of
seats in left field the franimal gets
loose his third straight hit in the ball
game 12-3 cleveland two down here's
miguel cino with a three-run homer and a
double
swing and a miss struck him up that'll
end it and end the season series against
minnesota the final tonight the
cleveland indians 12 and the minnesota
twins three